foreign
joins us up next in Ohio Sharon welcome
to the show
hi
um how are you guys we are doing great
what's going on with you
um so so I am a stay-at-home mom and my
husband
he moves up every year and so my
question is
um we still owe my parents around twenty
thousand dollars for they helped us buy
our house that we're in right now
um how can I convince my husband to
focus on paying off that debt rather
than just going slowly and then in the
meantime making extra cash here and
there and then using that extra cash for
fun things like vacations and hobbies
and stuff
um there's something about owing your
parents money
and then you go on vacation and it just
you know I mean I know the whole thing
feels ugh uh okay I've got to ask how
have you tried so far
um so we have a budget and we
um at this point we're doing like a
certain amount each month like we're
saving it up um or
um and then paying every couple months
we'll give Mom and Dad a check so you're
not doing you're not following the
babies you're not you're not trying to
get out of debt you just have like kind
of a plan you're kind of like messing
around but y'all aren't actually exactly
find a pile of money we'll give them a
little bit yeah
yeah pretty much I mean like it is a
goal like we've talked about it both of
us and we know that that's what we want
to do but I guess he's not as intense
about it as I am at this point and being
a stay-at-home mom I don't have any
other income really other than his which
is fine except that when he goes and
spends his extra income other than his
salary on fun stuff so what's the extra
income and I don't really get the extra
fun stuff if that makes sense where's
the extra income coming from
um things like um extra mechanic work
for friends or um working overtime at
his job they had a big project they had
to get done so he got paid extra stuff
like that but he sees this as well this
wasn't in the budget this is extra money
I earned I'm just gonna go spend it how
I want
pretty much yeah I mean when I asked him
when I ask him about it usually he'll
say oh yeah well we can put some of it
towards the loan or whatever
yeah he doesn't have the fire that that
you do to get this debt out of your life
and uh exactly when you're in baby step
two it's intense and you can do other
plans but our plan is this is scorched
Earth We're not eating out we're not
going on vacation we are we have one job
to do and that is get this debt out of
our life do you have any other debt
outside of the personal loan to your
family
um there's a little left on the mortgage
but otherwise no okay
well I think that obviously we got to
get him on the same page and it's hard
for you to do which I'm sure is
frustrating because you don't have the
ability to go create extra income to uh
to do this well actually actually you do
okay so let me hop in here George
um Sharon
somebody told you that the way you feel
doesn't matter who was that
is that was that when you were little
um possibly okay because you've carried
that message that's a story you were
probably told at some point and now it's
a story you tell yourself that
um you wish things were different but
this is just the way this is
and I know I feel this way but he works
hard and that's fine I'm not gonna fight
him and okay
and you are slowly
drowning
and what I would say is a pool of apathy
Fair
yeah that's fair and so
what the reason I asked you earlier what
have you tried and you you did what many
peacekeepers do
is you deflected to well we we have a
budget and we kind of do these things
what that tells me is you have a budget
every month and he either over like a
football game or something he'll look up
and be like yeah that's great
and he'll make some more money and keep
whatever he wants and you are doing this
and you are doing the best you can to
use the word we so that you don't feel
isolated alone am I right
yeah okay
so
at some point you're gonna have to
decide and my hope is that you take
initiative on the front end before this
thing turns into resentment because
that's where it's headed is that you
make a call a direct call honey I'm
scared to death
I'm sick of owing my parents money
and it makes me feel less than and it
makes me feel unsafe and I hate going on
vacation and having my dad look at the
photos on social media because It
embarrasses me that I had to go ask my
daddy and my mommy for money to buy my a
grown-up house I want this debt out of
our life please join with me on this
yes that is different than hey honey
it's budget time oh okay you see what
I'm saying and here's the thing if he if
he rolls if he rolls his eyes and says
no then you can say that I'm gonna have
to go get a job because I'm not living
like this anymore
right yeah well to be fair he does help
with the budget in fact it's
it's not it's not if I help with the
budget but then go make extra money that
doesn't apply to our goal which is do a
budget so that we can get out of debt
then I'm not really following a plan I'm
just kind of doing what I want to do yes
if if if you all had this great
agreement that y'all weren't gonna uh
y'all were married and y'all are gonna
hook up with other people and he was
very committed to you and he hooked up
with somebody on the side you would not
say he's a person of Integrity
infidelity
right and so saying we do this budget
together we do it 50 50. yeah cool
you'll talk about it together but y'all
aren't living the y'all the reason you
have a budget is because it gets you to
your goals it helps you feel safe it's
not just like an exercise and yeah he
may be 50 50 you may do the exercise
with you but he's not living it out and
you can't control him all you can
control is you and so I think it's fair
for you to sit down with him and tell
him probably for the first time here's
what this is doing to me I can't breathe
I can't I can't yeah I can't think of my
parents and owing them money anymore can
we please stop and can I ask you one
more question
sure it you're like sorry
um but not sorry
um
what else are you worried about
because this is symptomatic of something
bigger going on in your marriage what is
it
no not really Sharon honestly I mean we
we have a great marriage we really do
and this is just um this has just been
I'd say the last couple months I think
okay one thing I will mention that could
be
um
holding me up a little bit is okay right
now currently in the bank we do have a
little pile of money that we're planning
to give to Mom and Dad
um and I've told him once I was like
well couldn't we give them if you want
to save it up for like a rainy day or
whatever couldn't we give them a little
bit at a time just so I can feel that
motivation that I can still feel like
we're making some sort of progress you
know I told him it doesn't have to be
much and he's like well he would rather
do one chunk one big chunk at a time
he's like if I were mom and dad I would
want a big check not not multiple small
ones or whatever so what if y'all solve
this problem by just asking your dad
yeah we could do that I guess has there
been any conversation with when you're
going to pay this back to them
no honestly there hasn't no it was quite
it was like five or six years ago when
this first uh when we first borrowed the
money and at that point we were like
yeah Mom and Dad will pay you back but
there wasn't really a timeline attack it
would help your marriage it would help
your relationship with your family and
quite honestly would help the respect
between your husband and your dad
between each other just just got a guy
there
um if you all created a amortization
schedule you all created a schedule and
you printed it out on us on an Excel
spreadsheet or emailed it to each other
and said hey by the way we've created a
payment plan here because I've also
heard George I've heard of these
situations where you get to the end and
you're like that's 20 grand and then the
receiver on the other end of this money
goes uh no I've only got 18 four you
still owe me 1600 more right so Clarity
here Clarity Clarity Clarity let's put a
budget down in front of them talk to
your dad said you want a small monthly
sums you want every three and just say
hey we're painting this off in 10 months
it's two grand a month this thing's
gonna be gone and we're gonna be about
the business of doing that and any extra
work you're doing is going towards that
debt not just for fun money and that is
what doing a budget means as a couple
and it's going to take a hard
conversation it's going to take a better
budget I'm going to gift you one year of
every dollar premium to help you guys
get on that plan hang on the line Austin
we'll gift that to you wishing you guys
the best and getting rid of this debt